So I look to through documentation for AV Foundation framework.
By the way, a link to this website is also available in the instructor notes.
And in here when I scroll down,
I came across this class called AVAudioUnitTimePitch.
Now this seems like a very verbose name.
But when I clicked on it,
I found out that this class does exactly what we want to do.
It says that AVAudioUnitTimePitch, provides good quality playback rate and
pitch shifting.
Now, if I read through this class,
I find that it has a variable called pitch that I could change.
The documentation says that the default value of this variable, Is 1.0 and
the range of values for
this variable can be anywhere from negative 2400 to positive 2400.
All of this seems really promising.
All I need to do now, is to figure out how to use AVAudioUnitTimePitch.
And that's where you can help.
Your challenge is to find an example, Of how to use AVAudioUnitTimePitch.
And it's okay if you find an example on the internet that you don't
fully understand yet.
Specifically, I would love for you to identify any new websites that you thought
were promising, and then to try out any new code ideas that you discovered.
Check this box to continue.